I mean I think one of the most ephemeral
things that's happened to me is when I
was trying to take a picture of a deer
and you came across this footage
yesterday I was like sneaking up to it
no like pokes his head up and looks at
me and I'm like like all right I got to
get a good shine then it just charges me
and I just let it happen and yeah
shattered your entire skeleton yeah all
right
revered Institute at this weekend it's a
massive game we are gonna get into a
spoiler free discussion of like our
favorite ways to play this game Jake I
know you kind of like beelined it
through the main story you have any like
overall helpful tips on how to plan
don't don't rush it
there are mission side missions that you
that will that you'll get locked out of
if you don't do right away or close to
win they unlock so I definitely try to
shake all the trees you can see what's
to see what everything is I save your
laugh every day I don't kill you so we
are more than even on that front you'll
definitely get distracted here and there
but the story pulled me through the
entire way like I was partly rushing it
just because I wanted to see the end
before the game came out and have that
knowledge but at the same time you know
just like a lot of rockstar games that
story really keeps you going yeah cuz I
like obviously like in a rockstar game
you could sit down and play poker or
dominoes or whatever for like an hour or
GTA 5 and 40 to play darts or whatever
Belushi you kind of had that more of
that experience than going right to the
main story right yeah so I like didn't
want to rush the story because Red Dead
Redemption I love that game so much I
you know as many of us have waited eight
years for this and so I really wanted to
savor it take my time with it and also
it does a thing where it does encourage
you to go off the main story path and
just uncovered new things and so I
really and I'm enjoying just playing
that way and exploring and doing an
experiencing as much as I can yeah it's
like you'll be writing along a path from
like strawberry one of the towns to
Valentine and then all of a sudden
you'll hear someone that needs help or
gunshots and you'll write over and every
single time I heard that I was like it
was I was helpless I had to go check
Jake I know again you like beeline to
through the story because you also like
get pulled aside by those kind of like
emergence stuff happening in the world
star has like peppered throughout all
the time pretty much whenever I was
riding along anywhere and I saw that
little blip I'd immediately like alright
we're getting off the road here I want
to see what this is about and there
always be some sort of like interesting
unique interaction unified and get
anything out of it like like
material-wise like fighting Catan lorry
or or money it was still worth it like
it was still like a neat little
interaction that you know adds a lot to
both this world
yeah I think it was because everything
has a consequence and everything has an
impact like they take even just a
mundane what we do traditionally
consider a mundane like side mission and
an open well game it's like going
fishing with someone in your can
there'll be a spin on it they'll be like
a weird thing that happens that turns
into a thing that you know we've been
coming into the office every day and
going oh I found this really weird guy
like naked swimming through the lake or
whatever and there's also when you have
these random encounters there's kind of
always the knowledge that you might see
them again because I've been
encountering a bunch of people and
helping people out because I'm playing
as a good guy and I found them again and
the game is just really clever doling
out rewards like delayed rewards for
helping people yeah yeah it's some of
the most impressive moments I think in
that gamers all come across someone I'll
interact with them and I'll just forget
about it and then 10 hours later I'll
walk up and they'll be like hey I
remember you I didn't get your name and
they'll ask me for my name and like have
a little introduction it's really cool
it's really cool all right
Wallace this year's the kind soul I was
telling you about the one that are got
the venom out of your leg
mmm-hmm guess so listen friend I want to
talk about that honor system because
there's honourable and dishonourable I
guess would be the easy way to say it so
white side and a red side to your again
it's not morality but like Jake you
would kind of explained it as whether
it's like how good of a gang member you
are or what the sons of Dutch your gang
like are you are we all going kind of
good or did we all go kind of good I
want good or I went like honorable I
mean it's kind of like after playing Red
Dead Redemption
you know you've got John who's trying to
do the right thing yeah and I'm kind of
taking that mentality as I'm playing his
office it's like sure I've led a bad
life but I'm trying to do the right
thing and I think I'm really enjoying
the game by playing honor but you're
trying to because he like Arthur will
people will always say oh you're such a
good person and he like doesn't want to
be a good person so I feel like he is
like you to point he's exactly the
opposite of John Marston or at least my
version of Arthur that I'm plenty
because he's like I'm not a good person
shut up and just he wants to appear bad
but I think he is especially within the
context of the gang members he's one of
the better people at least so far I'm
like forty hours and I've not gotten
anywhere near beating the story maybe
something bad happens at the end I don't
know Jake feels fine I'm gonna spoil
anything but I my first playthrough I
played very nice I feel like a good
Arthur and now I'm kind of dipping into
the to the dishonorable side yeah and it
is harder like if you go up and
antagonize someone too much they'll just
like alright you're disturbing the peace
I'm gonna go tell the cops and they'll
run off and you have to like stop the
witness and then yeowch I'll beat them
something like don't tell anyone and
then six other people will see and
they'll run and it just it gets so out
of hand but it is pretty entertaining
being evil
I'm playing through it as an honorable
character but I really cannot wait to
replay it as an outlaw because the game
is very very good at making you feel
like an outlaw like when you write oh
it's an error into an area and you see
there's a bounty on you you actually
kind of get like yeah and I'm like I
feel like people are watching it cuz
look at the world is very good at
reacting to you and responding to you
and I feel like when you're an outlaw of
the game like super recognizes that and
really makes you feel like one like are
you going to town and I'm like I should
not be here no one wants me here yeah
I'm very clear away from sheriffs from
the Sheriff's Office
yeah I went into a time when I had a
bounty on and I put my mask on and
everyone's going hey what you hiding
your face yeah what are you doing I
don't see the need for that mask here if
you're playing is a good guy so the
control scheme is I would say quite
sophisticated there was a lot that you
can't really have to keep in mind and if
you accidentally like fire your gun or
you accidentally walk your horse over
someone which I do all the time you
walking around in town you genuinely
feel bad about it it feels like there's
more like no punishment is not the word
but it's definitely when you do stuff
wrong ya feel guilty like run someone
over it's like oh here their bones crack
yeah yeah
I just I love that the the honor system
actually makes the world different like
you would mention apparently there's
like hidden stuff like with within that
system that makes the weather change yes
there's like a little things that that
change depending on that that don't
necessarily like happen amongst the
people in the game like people like like
more than just the people like
apparently the weather would change and
like Arthur has a journal and depending
on how honorable is what kind of affect
what he draws right now like his
internal thoughts on paper yeah that's
really cool the journal like where's the
journaling about the best way yeah in
terms of like there's no right way to
play this game but I would heartily
recommend reading the journal whenever
possible it gets updated cuz it's just
cool to see Arthur's inner monologue I
do want to talk about how many different
Hut options there are because you can
almost turn a complete or you can't turn
it completely off like if you go
first-person obviously like I personally
don't think first-person is the best way
to play this game
I think there are so many small details
and third person that you see like the
way he swings his shotgun over shoulder
and then the way he's holding his rifle
when he's got like the Max Payne 3 style
of weapon holding you did bring up
something that's kind of a useful tip
though you were saying you did first
person indoors when you're like yeah
boring then seems like a smart idea yeah
there are some missions where you know
you have to go through houses or like if
it's a high dog that you like you've
killed everyone and you just want to go
and see if there's any treasure or
anything yeah first person makes it a
lot easier to get around but it's still
I'm doing third yeah I just yeah there's
like you said there's so many cool
animations that author and self has that
I don't want to do that by being in
first person dear
Jeremiah speaking of that I've kind of
like in terms of hygiene I've tried to
always be like clean shaven and like
like that kind of dapper looking I guess
but I want to see what it looks like
when I throw out a full beard hair mud
dirty I want to see like I know the camp
members will react to you if you are too
dirty and I want to see that because
right now they just keep they've said
literally they keep calling me a pretty
boy in town and stuff and Arthur
sometimes
you can also change the compass or but
you know you can change the mini-map
into a compass or you could turn it
completely off and then it only comes up
when you tap a button
I like that at first but then I just
kept the mini-map open the whole time
because sometimes when I heard gunshots
in the distance I wouldn't know exactly
where they were in the map would be a
flashing blip and I don't want to miss
anything I turn the mini-map back on so
I personally kept the normal Rockstar
mini-map on like the whole game but I
think you because you were the first one
that said like oh you could turn it off
and then just like manually bring it up
did you play the whole game like that no
I started to just for capturing footage
because I look cleaner without all of
that but you're right kind of like right
when I see like when I hear something
going on I know there's a blip on the
radar not being able to see that bullet
this kind of it makes it tough I keep
mine off like the whole time but it's if
I hear something that's when I'll just
tap down and it pops up for a little bit
yeah out of the blue
yeah like you said it's clean it just
looks really good and then the game is
so beautiful that I just yeah don't want
my I don't want to be constantly
focusing on the bottom left-hand corner
yeah
[Music]
when I first turned it off I was in a
cart and with so many other characters
and they changed the dialogue to tell me
you know go left up here go right go
through the trees and go laughs like
it's really go left here down the Main
Street I've noticed it's kind of hit or
miss though I think you brought up that
if they're in the middle of like talking
about something else they won't really
direct you unless you miss a turning and
then they'll go what are you doing
you're supposed to turn right yeah there
is one more thing that I do want to ask
you guys about cinematic mode do you
guys use that much because I found
myself using that all the time just
because if you plot a course on the map
and then you go to cinematic mode Arthur
will just like auto ride which is super
useful and it looks stunning it's really
good looking but and then also like it
confuses me sometimes in a good way
because they'll go into an actual rock
scene and I'll be like wait why is it
not turn me off I'm like oh [ __ ] it's
just transition pretty seamlessly yeah I
used it a lot earlier in the game and
then as the game went on I started not
using it just because I kind of enjoyed
really controlling my horse and because
you still can't control your horses and
ammo but this was very much like I could
see myself doing it later in my
playthrough as I'm just like okay I just
want to get to point B in a really
good-looking way as opposed to like a
more involved way and it takes ages
actually to even get to the point where
you can unlock fast travel so I was
doing a cinematic mode a ton in the
beginning but now I'm just enjoying fast
travel more about no I'm not you can
fast travel I'm just enjoying like
looking around and seeing the sights
hey hey partner yeah in general like
obviously if this conversation didn't
highlight if there's like myriad ways to
play this game whether like through that
the HUD through your role-playing as
Arthur whether you're outlaw or like
relatively good gang member but I guess
that's kind of the beauty the game it
lets you play exactly how you want and
discover it how you want like go through
the main story or just like take your
time hopelessly getting distracted by
every little detail
[Music]
[Music]